THEN YOU CAN DO WHATEVER THE
HELL YOU WANT.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR
DeSANTIS, A MAN ON THE SIDE
OF SAFETY AND FREEDOM FOR HIS
CITIZENS JOINS US NOW.
GOVERNOR, THANK YOU FOR BEING
WITH US TONIGHT.
AFTER YOU MADE YOUR
ANNOUNCEMENT, I KNOW YOU
PROBABLY MISSED THIS.
YOU WERE A LITTLE BUSY.
BUT CNN’S DR. SANJAY GUPTA HAD
THIS TO SAY.
>> THE IDEA OF REOPENING WHEN
WE ARE NOWHERE NEAR
CONTAINMENT, ETHERE IS TOO
MUCH VIRAL TRANSMISSION.
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS WENT
THROUGH THIS BEFORE.
THEY HAD A BIG SPIKE WHEN THEY
REOPENED.
THAT IS A CONCERN.
INSIDE RESTAURANTS WITH FULL
CAPACITY.
THERE IS NO MASK MANDATE.
THERE ARE NO FINES.
THESE ARE ALL THE WRONG SORT
OF DECISIONS AS FAR AS
ACTUALLY TRYING TO BRING THIS
PANDEMIC UNDER CONTROL.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, YOU ARE
GOING TO GET A LOT OF THIS.
THEY ARE WAVING THE CAUTION
FLAG.
THE DANGER FLAG.
THE WARNING FLAG TONIGHT ABOUT
YOUR DECISION.
WHY ARE YOU RIGHT AND WHY ARE
THEY WRONG?
>> WELL, I THINK A LOT OF THEM
ARE IGNORANT ABOUT FLORIDA.
WE NEVER CLOSED DOWN OVER THE
SUMMER.
HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE SUN
BELT SPIKE.
WE ACTUALLY HAD, OF COURSE,
BEACHES, THEME PARKS, RETAIL
OPERATING AT 100%.
WE HAD SPORTS AND SUMMER CAMPS
OVER THE SUMMER.
WE HAVE OVER 1.1 MILLION
STUDENTS IN FACE-TO-FACE
INSTRUCTION FOR K-12.
WE HAVE COLLEGE STUDENTS THAT
ARE ON CAMPUS.
WE HAVE HAD BIG EVENTS; SUCH
AS, NFL WITH THE FANS.
COLLEGE FOOTBALL WITH FANS.
WE HAD A NASCAR RACE WITH
30,000 PEOPLE.
SO, WE HAVE BEEN OPEN.
THE FINAL KIND OF PIECE TO THE
PUZZLE WAS THIS CAPACITY
LIMITATION ON THE RESTAURANTS
AT 50%.
SO THAT WAS THE ANNOUNCEMENT
TODAY THAT BROUGHT THAT IN FOR
A LANDING.
A LOT OF THOSE FOLKS IN THAT
INDUSTRY HAVE HAD A REALLY,
REALLY ROUGH TIME.
THEY HAVE LEARNED A LOT ABOUT
HOW TO CREATE A SAFE
ENVIRONMENT.
I THINK THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
DO THAT GOING FORWARD.
I THINK IT WILL END UP BEING
GOOD FOR JOBS.
I THINK IT WILL BE GOOD FOR
THEIR BUSINESS.
I THINK, LAURA, WE HAVE TO
HAVE A SITUATION WHERE
INDIVIDUALS CAN MAKE DECISIONS
ABOUT WHAT MAKES SENSE FOR
THEM.
IF IT’S SOMETHING YOU ARE NOT
COMFORTABLE DOING, NOBODY WILL
FORCE YOU TO DO IT.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE NEED TO BE
FREE TO CHOOSE.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT JOE BIDEN SAID
THIS WEEK ON THE TRAIL ABOUT,
"NATIONAL STANDARDS."
>> Former Vice Pres. Biden:
THE PRESIDENT HAS TO TAKE
CONTROL.
HAS TO TAKE RESPONSIBILITY.
SET NATIONAL STANDARDS.
MAKING SURE WE ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE THE PRESIDENT
LAYS OUT STANDARD FOR OPENING
SCHOOLS, OPENING BUSINESSES.
>> Laura: WELL, THAT ENDS UP
BEING CODE FOR "NATIONAL MASK
MANDATES" AND "ROLLING
LOCKDOWNS" WHICH FRANKLY
AMERICANS ARE JUST SICK AND
TIRED OF.
THEY ARE BEYOND THIS.
IN FACT, GOVERNOR, A GUEST WE
HAD ON LAST NIGHT WAS ARRESTED
EARLIER THIS WEEK FOR NOT
WEARING A MASK OUTSIDE.
WATCH.
>> [SINGING]
>> THEY SHOULD NOT BE DOING
THIS.
DOING THIS CUPID OF CRAP FOR
THE MAYOR.
THIS IS -- DOING THIS KIND OF
CRAP FOR THE MAYOR.
THIS IS EMBARRASSING.
>> C’MON.
>> [YELLING]
>> OVER A MASK.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, THESE
LOOK LIKE SCENES OUT OF
RUSSIA.
A MAN SINGING A HYMN WITH
OTHERS.
A WOMAN SITTING AT A SPORTS
EVENT.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
WHAT IS THIS REALLY ALL ABOUT?
>> WELL, I WILL TELL YOU,
LAURA.
IN FLORIDA WE NEVER DID ANY OF
THAT.
BUT IN OTHER STATES YOU WOULD
SEE CHURCHES BE BANNED.
BUT YOU COULD GO TO A CASINO.
BASIC RIGHTS DEPRIVED.
IT WAS OFTEN TIMES ON A
POLITICAL BASIS.
I AM WORRIED THOUGH ABOUT
THIS.
JOE BIDEN SAID HE WILL LOCK
DOWN THE COUNTRY IF A
SCIENTIST TELLS HIM TO DO IT.
I HAD A GREAT ROUND TABLE.
IT’S ON MY TWITTER AND
FACEBOOK WITH THREE VERY
IMMINENT SCIENTISTS YESTERDAY
TALKING ABOUT ALL THESE ISSUES
ISSUES.
DR. CALDORF, MICHAEL LEFT FROM
STANFORDLEVITT.I SAID SHOULD LOC
THE TABLE?
THEY ALL SAID THEY SHOULD BE
OFF THE TABLE.
THEY JUST DELAY INFECTIONS.
THEY DO NOT REDUCE THE
MORTALITY.
BUT THEY CAUSE CATASTROPHIC
DAMAGE.
THAT SHOULD BE OFF THE TABLE
IN THIS COUNTRY GOING FORWARD.
WE NEED OUR SOCIETY TO
FUNCTION.
BECAUSE COVID-19 IS ONE HEALTH
ISSUE.
THERE IS A WHOLE HOST OF OTHER
HEALTH ISSUES OUT THERE THAT
GET EXACERBATED WHEN YOU HAVE
SOCIETY ON ITS KNEES.
>> Laura: I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE STATE OF FLORIDA AND
THE PRESIDENTIAL RACE,
GOVERNOR DeSANTIS.
GIVEN HOW CLOSE IT WAS LAST
TIME AROUND.
THE PRESIDENT HAS EXPRESSED
HIS EXTREME CONCERN WITH
MAIL-IN VOTING.
NOT ABSENTEE VOTING WHICH IS
VERY POPULAR IN YOUR STATE.
BUT WITH THE MAIL-IN VOTING.
HOW DO YOU THINK THINGS STAND
NOW IN THE STATE GIVEN WHERE
THE POLLS ARE AND WHERE YOU
THINK THE PEOPLE ARE AFTER
THIS DIFFICULT YEAR?
>> WELL, JUST BE CLEAR.
WE DON’T HAVE MASS MAIL VOTING
IN FLORIDA.
WE HAVE MAIL VOTING ON
REQUEST.
ABSENTEE VOTING.
VOTERS CAN REQUEST IT.
THEY WILL GET SENT A BALLOT.
THEY CAN SEND IT IN.
IT’S TRIED, TRUE AND SAFE.
SO IF PEOPLE WANT TO VOTE THAT
WAY, THEY SHOULD DO IT.
BUT WE ARE NOT INDISCREMNANTLY
SENDING OUT --
INDISCRIMINATELY SENDING
BALLOTS ALL OVER THE STATE.
I THINK HE IS IN GOOD SHAPE.
IT’S TOUGH HERE.
THIS IS NEVER AN EASY RACE.
IF YOU LOOK FOR 2016 HE DID
REALLY POORLY IN MIAMI-DADE
COUNTY.
STILL WON THE STATE.
HE DOING A LOT BETTER IN
MIAMI-DADE.
HE HAS REALLY STRONG SUPPORT
FROM HISPANICS.
I THINK HE WILL WIN HISPANICS
IN MIAMI-DADE COUNTY.
IF HE HOLDS THE SUPPORT
ELSEWHERE, YOU KNOW, I THINK
HE DEFINITELY GOING TO BE IN
GOOD SHAPE.
BIDEN REALLY NOT DONE MUCH IN
FLORIDA.
YOU KNOW, WE HAVE A GROUND
GAME.
WE ARE STEGEERING VOTERS GOING
OUR -- WE ARE REGISTERED
VOTERS GOING DOOR TO DOOR.
THEIR CAMPAIGN HASN’T WANTED
TO DO THAT BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC.
WHEN TRUMP WON IN 2016 WE HAD
340,000 VOTE DEFICIT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS WITH REGISTRATION.
WE HAVE SHRUNK THAT TO UNDER
190,000.
THAT IS AS CLOSE AS WE HAVE
EVER BEEN PROBABLY IN MODERN
HISTORY IN TERMS OF THE
REGISTRATION.
THAT BODES WELL FOR US.
>> Laura: ARE YOU WORRIED
ABOUT MICHAEL BLOOMBERG’S
EFFORTS TO PAY THE PENALTIES,
THE FINES OF FORMER FELONS WHO
WOULD THEN GET THE RIGHT TO
VOTE IF THEIR FINES WERE PAID?
$16 MILLION.
>> OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING THAT.
A SITUATION HE IS DOING IT.
DISCRIMINATING ON THE BASIS OF
RACE.
ONLY PAYING OFF IF YOU ARE A
CERTAIN RACE.
I THINK SOMEONE IN THE
ORGANIZATION SAID YEAH,
BECAUSE WE THINK THEY WILL
VOTE FOR THE CANALED DATE WE CAN
WANT.
BUT IN FLORIDA IT MAY RUN
AFOUL OF THAT.
THIS IS BEING INVESTIGATED BY
THE STATE ATTORNEY GENERAL IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA.
>> Laura: GOVERNOR, JUST ONE
MORE TIME.
I’LL ASK ONE MORE QUESTION.
WILL YOU EVER CONSIDER LOCKING
DOWN YOUR STATE, LARGE PARTS
OF YOUR STATE AS THE GOVERNOR
OF NEW YORK, I GUESS THEY ARE
NOW CONSIDERING IT IN NEW YORK
CITY TODAY, WE LEARNED,
BECAUSE OF SOME OUTBREAK.
YOU WILL NEVER DO THAT IN YOUR
STATE.
>> 0% CHANCE OF THAT.